[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
let's get to Valerie in Atlanta Georgia
Valerie what's going
on hi thank you both so much for taking
my call I greatly appreciate being here
sure um sometimes I try to use humor to
get through things so if I say something
and y'all are laughing at it but I'm
serious at the same time I am new I'm
kind of ramsy is trying to be much more
involved um I was on the um Ken Coleman
show not once but twice um he didn't
tell me I was a hot mess but I've heard
Dave Ramsey say basically some of the
things that I'm experiencing I'm a hot
mess I have the mind of a gazelle but
I'm waddling around like a penguin I
can't get I can't get anywhere I'm
that's self aware at least Valerie I
appreciate that
Honesty so how can we help if Ken
Coleman couldn't help you who can
what's going on I'm sorry oh you're good
you're good so you're 58 and you sound
like you're scared to death and and he's
thinking yeah John you can you can help
me that's why he hooked me up with you
he said I really probably needed needed
to talk to you um I wanted to come to
the book signing we don't have any money
so basically I'm married to somebody
much I'm trying to talk fast and if I
talk too fast let me know but I'm trying
to get it all in because it's a big mess
okay a huge huge big mess go for it I
had an accident four years ago um Ken
tried to get you know Ken coach me along
a little bit about trying to get a
better paying job I was making six
figures I'm not even making but $16
working a big box retail now and it's
extremely stressful and the hours are
from 11: to 8 so I can't really get a
serving job you know at night or do
other things but anyway long story short
I've been doing a lot of trying to get a
new job I've uh been in counseling twice
a week because
I'm I had to learn to walk again I had
to learn to get out of bed by myself my
husband was by my side um this happened
in another country in the Netherlands
but when I came home I couldn't do
anything and he was still stuck in the
Netherlands I was back here in the stat
and couldn't do anything um by myself I
had to go to therapy and everything this
happened about four years ago so I'm a
financial wreck 58 no savings don't even
have I can't even pay my bills my my
money doesn't even cover my bills but
I'm so
anxious and sometimes honestly I do
still like in term life insurance policy
because Dave says have term rather than
whole I do have that and I feel like I'm
worth more dead than alive I mean I
can't I can't get out of this mess I I
just don't know where's
husband husband is 75 can't work um here
in the states legally and he's retired
so he is somewhat on the same page with
you know he does help a little bit every
month very little because he still got a
place it's a long story but I mean he
does not even have a green card in our
country because that's $5,000 we don't
have um so you're the your sole income
for the house making 16 an hour how much
debt do you guys
have we have as as a couple I mean it's
me uh this is all prior to us being
married 47,000 um go over that that's
why I'm in such a horrific horrific
shape and Ken told me to talk to you
guys because not only am I anxious every
day and nervous and just a financial
wreck um 20 of that is two Parent Plus
Loans um I'm 145 upside down in my truck
have tried to work out a settlement
don't know I mean like I can't even buy
a hoopie there's no way to even go out
and buy one of those to get you know to
do the side hustles I'm not not an
excuse maker no you're stuck hold on
hold on hold on yeah I'm stuck couple
things you're
stuck and you ain't going to hear that
from George and I that we're going to
clown on you you're in an absolute mess
and I want you to make complete and
total peace with your body if the
anxiety alarms weren't ringing off the
hook at inside your body I would tell
you you need to go to a physician
immediately your anxiety right now means
your body is working about perfectly
it's perfect okay so hang on the line
we're going to roll this call over we're
going to go to break and then we come
back we're going to walk you through
some potential challenges and some
potential opportunities this is a mess
and this is very very hard I know that
you have been
repeatedly hit upside the head over the
last four or five or six years
right yes and when that happens to us
often we develop some pretty amazing um
defense mechanisms and so I want you to
do me a favor and I want you to tighten
your hands really tight right now can
you do that can you squeeze both your
hands as tight as you
can and then I want you to relax them
and open them up completely okay drop
your shoulders I'm going to Rattle a
bunch of stuff off for the sake of time
and then I'm going to hook you up with a
couple things at the end of this okay
but I want you to think through some of
these things all right thing number
one I want you to write a letter to your
former self that used to make six
figures that woman is haunting you right
now because you used to be incredible
right yes yeah and I think you still are
you're hanging in there you're a boxer
that's on the Rope but you're ropes but
you're still hanging in there and all
you can remember is when you used to be
champ and you can't see that act the
fighting that's going on right now
you're actually stronger and tougher
than you used to be okay I want you to
write her a letter and say you miss
her and but she's gone now and so what
we're going to do is we're going to deal
in the reality that we have here we're
going to shift that identity to who we
used to be to who we are and we are
Scrappy and tough now number two I want
you to have a hard conversation with
your kids and let them know I signed
these Parent Plus Loans I can't pay my
bills to
eat and I want you to tell them this is
embarrassing this is hard this is scary
whatever words you want to
use but that you need them to help with
the cost of their college education at
least for the foreseeable
future and they might tell you forget
you Mom we're not doing that whatever
you're right I signed my name on it and
if you want to watch your mom drown then
you can watch
that but I need some
help the third thing is I drove by this
morning morning my daughter and I went
to breakfast and I drove by a McDonald's
and on the sign it said 20 bucks an
hour I want you to take all of the
imaginary Pride you have and I want you
to you are locked into eight 8:00 to
11:00 p.m. job or whatever time you work
right now I want you to be very honest
about your local
area and it might be working at fast
food it might be working to fast food
jobs McDonald's in the morning Taco
Bell's in the evening or Arby's in the
morning and whatever I don't care cuz
right now we got to get that income
up
okay it's going to be a swallowing of
Pride that you is going to be I I I just
hurt for you and you're going to come
out on the back end of this so strong
the next thing I want you to do is I
want you to call the Social Security
office and see what the status is have
you already done
that what do you mean if you have a
disability that prohib you from doing
the work that you used to be able to do
you may be eligible for Social Security
early well I I I can actually I I was
going to tell you four years later I am
walking now I'm getting out of bed by
myself and I'm fine mentally I'm a mess
okay but physically I can I'm being real
I can actually work now I've been
applying that's why can said get some
help with your mental state and you know
and ask John for some advice on being so
anxious and why do you think hold on why
do you think you're a
mess
um I'm a mess because well I feel like
I'm a failure I you're asking me the
total picture feel like I'm a
failure going hold on not true go to the
next thing what's the next thing um I
feel like I'm not good enough okay not
true go to the next
thing my kids uh I I feel like a failure
to my my grown kids my kids are grown
that's false that's that's not true what
you've just told me is a lot of
feelings and you're being run by your
feelings not by
data and so it's an old cognitive
behavioral technique that any counselor
should have had you do which is to write
down these feelings that are burying you
and then I want you to demand evidence
from them is that true I feel like a
failure to my grown kids is that
true did I raise them feel how they see
me not hey they're grown-ups they can
see you however you want they may not be
true either
right I want you to take these thoughts
and I want you to write them down all
these feelings and challenge them take
them head on and if you can't see the
forest from the trees call your kid hey
I've been really wrestling with this
idea that I'm a failure is that
true no Mom we freaking love you we miss
you
and I want you to take those on I don't
think your body's screwed up I don't
think you're a mess if I had a 75
year-old person spouse my wife was 75
and I loved her and she couldn't work
and she was drowning in her own shame
and she was getting older and I was
terrified and I had this wreck and I
used to be a six-figure earner and now
I'm making 16 bucks an hour I'd be
anxious too every person on the planet
would be anxious that's why I don't know
that the anxi is the thing to go solve
right now I think the thing to solve
is fighting going to war against these
negative bull crap feelings because
they're not true you're not a failure
you're still
standing you're absolutely
incredible you have fought back from not
being able to get out of bed and now
you're
working now I want you to see that worth
more than 16 bucks an hour because
you're worth more than that
I want you to hang on the line because
this isn't just a one anddone thing okay
we're going to do a couple things number
one I'm going to hook you up with three
nope six I'm going to hook you up with
six months of free counseling with my
friends at better help you can do that
from home so you don't have to drive
anywhere okay it's it's online the
second thing is we're going to hook you
up with three sessions with a financial
coach with Ramsey Financial coaches for
free okay they're going to walk through
your budget specifically and they're
going to help pull apart and show you
that it is that bad and here's some
ideas or it's actually not that bad or
actually maybe it's in the middle you're
going to get some data some facts Okay
the third thing is I'm going to send you
three months free of every dollar the
app that you can track your money and
you can begin to get some little wins
little bits of control over this thing
slowly and
surely anxiety comes when we project the
future is going to be a certain way and
it SC scares us and we start trying to
solve it in the present and it's an
imaginary
future you have to head into that
anxiety I'm terrified about what comes
next cool I'm going to go figure out
what comes next I'm terrified I'm not
going to have enough money cool I'm
going to go get a second job and a third
job because now I can get up I'm
terrified about count about my feelings
cool I'm going to see a counselor and
I'm going to use CBT techniques I'm
going straight after these feelings that
aren't true we're going right into the
storm and we're going to hook you up
with people to walk with you thank you
for being brave thank you for the call
you are awesome awesome awesome good
stuff John thank you for that one last
thing Valerie the first thing you buy is
food the next thing you need to buy is
shelter the next thing is utilities
we're paying for light paying for the
water bill and the next thing is
clothing basic necessities that's it
that means the car loan folks they can
kick rocks and pound sand because you
don't have the money to pay the student
loan companies they can also kick rocks
and pound sand because you don't have
the money to pay you come first the
creditors they can wait and I love
John's advice about getting the kids to
pitch in even though it's legally on you
I think the kids need to step up and
help Mom in her time of need and we can
get you out outside of this upside down
truck situation you need to go over
there and say listen you got a bad loan
on your hands I need the difference to
get out of this mess and you're going to
have to fight that to get out of that
mess and get you something you can drive
to work but we're rooting for you
America is rooting for you and John
hooked you up with so many resources
that I hope helps you take the Right
Next Step this is the ramsy show